en el último vídeo vimos la
clasificación de elementos en grupos en
la tabla periódica y paramos para la
definición de metal de transición hay
dos maneras de pensar en metales de
transición una manera de pensar en ello
sería cuando algún profesor habla de
metales de transición se refiere a
elementos provenientes del grupo 3 al
grupo 12 todos estos elementos de aquí
algunas personas los consideran como los
metales de transición estos son los
elementos delimitados por el bloque d
estamos hablando de orbitales de aquí
así que debes de entender
configuraciones electrónicas para este
vídeo
esa es una manera de pensar en los
metales de transición pero esa manera es
algunas veces demasiado general por lo
que hay otra definición que podríamos
encontrar en la página web de la iupac
iupac es el acrónimo para la unión
internacional de química pura y aplicada
en que un elemento de transición se
refiere a un elemento cuyo átomo tiene
un sub nivel de incompleto estamos
hablando de los orbitales de ya sabemos
que hay cinco orbitales de y cada
orbital tiene un máximo de dos
electrones
5 x 2 es 10 por lo que 10 sería el
máximo número de electrones que podría
caber en tus orbitales de juventud psuv
nivel de contemos eso en nuestra tabla
periódica son 10 12
4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10 para nuestro bloque de
continuamos escribiendo una
configuración electrónica para nuestro
metal de transición y veamos cómo aplica
eso a nuestra definición de iupac
escribamos la configuración electrónica
para el hierro aquí está el hierro y si
quisiera escribir una configuración
electrónica digamos que quiero usar la
anotación de gas noble nuevamente estoy
asumiendo que ya saben hacer esto no
pasará mucho tiempo hablando de esto
pero si quisiera escribir una
configuración de gas noble me iría al
árbol que
el gas noble antes del hierro pondré al
árbol dentro de corchetes
y eso me lleva al cuarto nivel de
energía en el cuarto periodo de la tabla
periódica y luego solo viendo la tabla
periódica podría decir eso sería 4 s 14
s 2 déjame escribir 4 s 2 aquí y luego
estoy en mi orbital d
solo viendo la tabla periódica para
escribir mi configuración electrónica
diría 1 2
456 electrones
eso sería 3
6 y pude haber escrito esto
d
4 es
y en este momento ambas están
consideradas como buenas respuestas y no
hablaré del orden de llenado de estos
orbitales en este vídeo guardaré ese
tema para otro vídeo este vídeo es solo
para definiciones e identificar
elementos en la tabla periódica y
entonces cualquiera de estas sería una
configuración electrónica adecuada y
cuando veo los orbitales d cuando veo
los orbitales d para la configuración
electrónica puedo ver que hay 6
electrones en mis orbitales de y ese es
un sub nivel de incompleto porque pueden
caber un total de 10 n orbital de y
entonces el hierro sería un ejemplo de
un elemento cuyo átomo tiene un orbital
de incompleto
el hierro es un metal de transición
ahora escribamos la configuración
electrónica para el cic así que
encontremos al zinc por aquí justo ahí
en la tabla periódica escribiré la
configuración electrónica para el zinc
nuevamente iré al gas noble antes de él
que es el argón pondré al árbol dentro
de unos corchetes
y luego nuevamente me lleva a un nivel
de energía 4 tenemos 4 s 14 s 24
2 y cuento mis electrones en el orbital
de 12
4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10
3 de pie
y nuevamente por haber escrito al argón
dentro de unos corchetes
4 s 2 realmente no importa pensemos en
la definición para un metal de
transición un elemento cuyo átomo tiene
un su nivel de incompleto si veo los
orbitales de para ir sin que están
completamente llenos tengo 10 electrones
en mis orbitales de iu entonces este es
un sub nivel de completo no cumple con
la definición de elementos de transición
en la definición también se habla de
canciones cierto así que pensemos en el
castellón que formaría el cic el sic
sería
52 más si quisiera escribir la
configuración electrónica para 52 más
debo de pensar en donde perdió en 52
electrones si vamos de un átomo neutral
de zinc a cientos más
deberás perder 2 electrones ya sé que
esos dos electrones se perderán del
orbital 4 es así que perderemos estos
dos electrones aquí en tu configuración
electrónica y entonces nos quedamos con
3 de 10
y nuevamente tienes un campeón que tiene
un nivel de completo llenas tus
orbitales de por completo el camión no
tiene un sub nivel de incompleto lo que
significa que no cumple con nuestra
definición técnica de un elemento de
transición de la iupac y entonces hay
dos maneras de pensar en eso una es una
forma muy general
podrías escuchar a alguien referirse a
un elemento de los grupos 3 al 12 como
un metal de transición o podrías
encontrar a personas que se van más por
la definición de la iupac y es bueno
conocer las dos maneras de pensar en
estos elementos